le rpr déterminer lui des organismes
bonsoir la pologne tout d'abord la
semaine prochaine sera très importante
pour les polonais je sais qu'on le dit
souvent depuis un an
mais le congrès de solidarité qui a
repris aujourd'hui sera cette fois
cruciale de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit de savoir si le syndicat de
lech walesa va confirmer les positions
d'acier aux prises au début de ce mois à
savoir réclamer des élections libres et
appelé les travailleurs des autres pays
de l'est à fonder des syndicats libres
et tout cela au moment où la vie
quotidienne est de plus en plus
difficile pour des millions de polonais
ligne a guère qu'en pologne à un congrès
syndical commence par une messe il est
vrai que solidarité aura bien besoin de
la protection divine pour éviter les
écueils qui personne sauf à l'intérieur
même du syndicat il ya la tendance
conciliatrice lèche valaisanne et les
durs qui vont remarque les accepter les
compromis compromis concernant l'auto
gestion par exemple réclamé par les plus
audacieux et la formule adouci accepté
par valaisanne sous la pression du
gouvernement
autre écueil plus redoutable le
gouvernement de varsovie qui commencent
à montrer les dents
cette fois-ci il n'a pas envoyé de
représentant au congrès de danse plus il
fait circuler ostensiblement des
patrouilles armées dans les rues ou
encore il refuse les visas d'entrée en
pologne à des délégués du syndicat
américain afl cio
il est vrai que les visas pour force
ouvrière viennent d'être accordés en
dernière minute les journalistes
français se prononcent pas ou pas encore
eu cette chance
autre menace ou circonstance génératrice
d'inquiétude les grèves qui viennent
d'éclater dans les mines de charbon de
silésie et qui ne sont pas faites pour
détendre l'atmosphère
enfin et ce n'est pas la moindre ombre
au tableau les avertissements multiplier
de l'union soviétique
il se dit inquiète de l'action qualifiée
d'anti socialiste et d'anti soviétique
de solidarité l'évêque solidarité dans
la première partie de son congrès a
lancé un appel aux travailleurs des
autres démocraties populaires pour les
invités à suivre son exemple et secouer
le joug officiel va-t-elle cette fois-ci
récidiver on se demande qui va
l'emporter de la prudence ou de l'audace
françois mitterrand au pays de l'or noir
le président de la république est arrivé
tout à l'heure en arabie saoudite pour
une visite officielle de 48 heures c'est
le premier voyage officiel de françois
mitterrand hors d'europe
pendant deux jours le chef de l'état
vienne va dialoguer avec le roi khaled
et le prince héritier fade
de nombreux dossiers techniques font
être discutée par les ministres mais le
sujet principal ce sera la paix au
proche-orient france et l'arabie
saoudite vont tenter de rapprocher leurs
positions sur ce problème
françois mitterrand est donc arrivé à tu
as tout à l'heure tu as fc la capitale
d'été du royaume saoudien
le reportage de l'un de nos envoyés
spéciaux bernard pradines au le roi
khaled d'arabie saoudite est venu
accueillir le président mitterrand à
l'aéroport de taiz cérémonie
présentation de la famille royale hymnes
nationaux formule de bienvenue et plus
tard échange de cadeaux
ce premier voyage officiel à l'étranger
de monsieur mitterrand en terre arabe a
une importance à la fois économiques et
politiques politique car la diplomatie
française est apprécié à ryad après le
10 mai les saoudiens ont été inquiets de
l'élection d'un socialiste ami d'israël
et nommant au gouvernement des ministres
communistes
le président français a su expliquer ces
objectifs le roi khaled a été le premier
chef d'état reçu à paris son frère le
prince fahd est ensuite venu à l'elysée
pour présenter son plan de paix sur le
proche orient pour monsieur mitterrand
les conditions de la paix passe par le
dialogue avec ceux qui le souhaitent y
compris les représentants du peuple
palestinien d'un autre côté les
saoudiens sont déçus par les etats-unis
qui viennent de choisir de livrer du
matériel militaire à israël et non pas à
eux
en même temps pour le roi khaled la
menace soviétique est de plus en plus
précises l'urss est en afghanistan et
elle vient de passer un accord avec le
sud yémen la libye et l'ethiopie
l'arabie saoudite se sent isolé sans
compter les critiques qu'elle subit de
la part de certains de ses partenaires
de l'opep ce contexte politique est un
lien supplémentaire pour les diplomaties
de paris et de riyad importance
économique également
l'arabie saoudite est le premier
fournisseur de pétrole de la france
en revanche les exportations françaises
ici ne vienne au sixième rang après les
états unis le japon l'allemagne fédérale
la grande bretagne et l'italie
monsieur mitterrand n'est pas venue par
les boutiques mais les cinq ministres
qu'il accompagne aujourd'hui auront la
possibilité d'évoquer l'amélioration des
échanges entre les deux pays
l'ol paie critiquent la position
française c'est la réaction de
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine aux propos tenus par françois
mitterrand sur le proche orient dans sa
conférence de presse jeudi dernier l'ol
paie reproche à la france son attitude
vis-à-vis d'israël estime que la
position de monsieur mitterrand n'est
toujours pas constructives à l'étranger
encore l'ulster 1/7 détenus républicain
arrêter la grève de la faim à la prison
de l'amav liane mccloskey c'est son nom
à 25 ans a arrêté sa grève de la faim
alors qu'il refusait de s'alimenter
depuis cinquante-cinq jours maintenant
qu'il se trouvait dans un état très
grave
cela renforce la position de madame
thatcher qui a toujours pensé que son
intransigeance se révélera finalement
payante
enfin à l'étranger encore l'iran la
campagne officielle pour l'élection
présidentielle a commencé tout à l'heure
l'élection aura lieu à la fin de la
semaine et devraient porter au pouvoir
le secrétaire général du parti de la
république islamique
l'actualité française maintenant avant
de passer aux problèmes politiques tout
d'abord le téléphone le président de la
république a laissé entendre que les ptt
pourrait prochainement envoyée aux
utilisateurs qui le souhaitent des
factures détaillées
vous pourrez ainsi savoir à l'avenir
combien vous ont coûté chacune des
communications vous avez comment se
présentera la facture et bien il suffit
de regarder ce qui se passe dans
certains pays étrangers qui pratiquent
déjà le système
c'est ce qu'a fait jean claude allanic
en regardant les factures américaine
factures fantaisistes et contestations
sans issue avec l'administration des ptt
tout cela sera bientôt fini et
prochainement les usagers du téléphone
pourront obtenir une facturation des
tailles et de toutes leurs
communications comme cela se fait déjà
aux états unis il sera donc possible de
vérifier si le montant de la facture
correspond bien aux appels effectués par
l'abonné avec peut-être quelques risques
de troubles pour la paix des ménages
puisque sur cette facture américaine
ultra détaillés on voit apparaître aussi
bien le jour de l'appel que leur la
durée la communication la destination le
numéro demandé et enfin le montant de la
facture ici trois dollars 18 cents
pour le ministre français des ptt où il
ya quelques jours encore on répétait que
la facturation détaillée n'était pas
envisageable dans l'immédiat le modèle
américain représente deux inconvénients
d'une part il coûte naturellement plus
cher que la facture globale et d'autre
part il va à l'encontre du principe du
respect et de l'inviolabilité de la vie
privée des citoyens
des arguments que rejeter les
associations de consommateurs et qui
apparemment n'ont pas convaincu non plus
le président mitterrand
toutefois la facture détaillée coûtera
plus cher et le sera communiqué aux
abonnés qui en feront la demande
perturbations à la sncf il s'agit d'un
mouvement de grève de 24 heures décidée
par quatre syndicats concrètement bien
la perturbation affectera surtout et
seulement même le réseau sud ouest la
région de bordeaux et de toulouse selon
la direction de la sncf un train sur
trois sur les grandes lignes demain dans
la direction paris province et 1 train
sur 2 dans la direction inverse la
politique maintenant l'opposition fait
le point et s'organise ce week end en
effet les deux composantes de
l'opposition c'est-à-dire le rpr d'une
part et l'udf de l'autre ces deux
mouvements se sont réunis et si cela se
passe bien chez les gaullistes il y a eu
en revanche des tiraillements à l'udf
d'abord donc les gaullistes réunis à la
baule qui étaient là pour les journées
parlementaires du rpr daniel brême à la
boule
nous sommes des résistants face à une
république que les socialistes tue à
petit feu
c'est en substance ce qu'a déclaré
olivier guichard en levant ce matin
l'étendard de la révolte
cette guerre au socialisme qualifié de
pervers doit être totale et ceux qui
voudront composés seront broyés
appelant à l'effort et à l'espérance qui
selon lui se traduiront lors des
élections locales 2 82 et 83 le public
sert à analyser sans complaisance les
raisons des échecs passés
nous avons été battus dit on sans savoir
un peu de quoi l'on parle par
l'inflation et le chômage des aventures
tout était battu à une perte tragique de
crédibilité politique quand je dis nous
je veux dire un président qui n'a jamais
su vivre avec toute sa majorité est
aussi un groupe comme le nôtre qui après
avoir pendant 20 ans habitué les
français aux situations claires et
nettes
laura donner l'impression qu'ils ne
savaient plus s'ils soutenaient le
pouvoir sans l'approuver ou s'il ne
combattait sent la patte
aujourd'hui il nous reste à regagner
notre crédibilité en nous maintenant
dans une opposition sans concession sans
dispersion et sans illusion tactique
le secrétaire général du rpr en présence
de jacques chirac a repris le thème du
combat des bons républicains contre les
marxistes collectiviste le rpr pourrait
abandonner son sigle pour ce type lors
des prochaines campagnes électorales
le docteur poncet beaucoup insisté sur
le fait que son mouvement était le mieux
placé je cite pour rassembler ceux qui
veulent s'y fait à la france et et
dangers du bouleversement en cours et
c'est ainsi que les français en sont
venus à comprendre la réalité pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux déjà à
regretter leur vote à tout cela à tous
ceux qui déçus nous rejoignent déjà à
tous ceux qui demain se tourneront vers
nous que devons nous dire
essentiellement ceux ci et je crois que
cela doit être la kz2 notre discours
politique
en politique rien et irréversible tout
ce qui se fait ou plutôt ceux d'été sous
nos yeux dans la précipitation et
souvent l'improvisation pourra être
modifié un jour ou l'autre par la
volonté du peuple
deuxième composante de l'opposition
l'udf là les choses se passent nettement
moins bien le parti républicain
le cds et les radicaux étaient eux aussi
réunis à paris mais chacun de leur côté
et dans trois endroits différents
ils n'ont pas du tout tenu les mêmes
propos pierre-alain est allé voir les
trois parties lorsqu'un chef de famille
est ailleurs il y a toujours des
problèmes de succession
en politique aussi ceux qui formaient
jusqu'à présent le parti giscardien
l'udf se sont réunis aujourd'hui à paris
réunit mais chacun de son côté pour
savoir comment désormais il
s'organiserait rester dans la même
famille
d'accord mais sans que chacun des
orphelins plus ou moins gourmand puisse
se sentir lésés le parti républicain par
exemple animée par jacques blanc faisait
figure d'enfant modèle fidélité à
giscard bien sûr mais démocratisation du
parti changement de tête à la direction
possibilité de s'exprimer pour ce qu'ils
représentent d'autres tendances
il faut bien se reconvertir en parti
d'opposition le parti républicain il n'a
jamais voulu venir de venir à lui tout
seul udf mais par contre partie
républicaine a affirmé ce matin sa
volonté d'être réellement ce grand parti
d'opposition capable d'être le point
d'ancrage pour les françaises et les
français qui veulent désormais se
mobiliser pour faire renaître l'espoir
dans ce pays
et le parti républicain à partir de sa
fidélité à valéry giscard d'estaing à
partir de son unité qui a été confirmée
ce matin entend jouer pleinement son
rôle de parti d'opposition nous étions
un parti de gouvernement nous sommes un
parti d'opposition est une opposition
combative
même souci mais avec d'autres nuances
chez les centristes de jean lecanuet
associés d'accord mais si l'on peut
s'exprimer
le cds d'ailleurs voudrait que l'union
pour la démocratie française change
d'étiquettes pour celle de fédérations
démocrate s'est à nouveau en particulier
qu'il appartient de faire en sorte de
lui df centre bien dans le centre au
centre centre gauche
l'udf mais jouera son rôle dans la vie
politique française que si elle apparaît
comme étant un mouvement du centre et
bien c'est à nous à faire en sorte qu
effectivement l'udf n'apparaissent pas
comme le parti de je ne sais quel la
restauration comme le parti de je ne
sais quelle droite mais comme à partie
dynamique comme un parti réformateur
comme un parti du centre débat très
animé en particulier chez les radicaux
la statue du commandeur ne plane plus
sur nos têtes entendait-on et nous ne
voulons pas servir de marche-pied à qui
que ce soit d'où cette volonté très
affirmée d'exister au sein d'une
nouvelle opposition
quitte à chercher ailleurs si la
cohabitation n'est pas possible nous
n'avons pas vocation à rester
minoritaire pour le long terme nous
voulons que l'opposition se remettent en
cause complètement et qu'elle se remette
en cause à tous les niveaux qu'à cet
égard d'ailleurs je vous informe que le
secrétaire-général du parti en valentino
et moi même avons décidé de demander à
jacques chirac de le rencontrer dans les
plus proches délais pour évoquer avec
lui les perspectives que pourrait
recouvrer cette nouvelle expression
d'opposition
et puis qui dit changement dit
changement d'homme s'il ne fait pas de
doutes avant leur congrès respectifs que
jean lecanuet jacques blanc et didier
bariani conserveront leur place ils
savent déjà qu'elles sont convoités
autre congrès politique le ps eut réunis
ce week-end à paris son conseil national
le ps va se situer de nouveau par
rapport au gouvernement
en bref encore le reste de l'actualité
politique pierre mauroy à lille il a
inauguré un centre de santé dans sa
ville il faut faire des économies dans
ce domaine a affirmé le premier ministre
les le financement des dépenses de santé
constitue at-il dit l'un des dossiers
les plus complexes que j'ai trouvé en
arrivant à l'hôtel matignon
enfin une prise de position d'antoine
pinay l'ancien président du conseil
il fait des compliments françois
mitterrand et souhaite que son action
réussissent dans l'intérêt du pays
économie 35 milliards de francs pour les
nationalisations
c'est le coût de l'indemnisation évalué
par la cob la commission des opérations
de bourse
les nationalisations on va en parler
beaucoup dans les semaines qui viennent
puisque le texte du projet de loi sera
soumis à l'assemblée le 8 octobre
prochain
c'est pourquoi lundi soir notre magazine
d'information à faire vous concernant
sera concernée sera contre sacré pardon
à ses problèmes de nationalisation jean
boissonnat qui animera le débat présente
le dossier
les nationalisations le gouvernement les
a décidé le président de la république
les a expliqué le parlement va débattre
quelques-uns des plus grands groupes
industriels français les banques
pratiquement toutes les banques vont
devenir la propriété de l'état
pourquoi comment ce sera le thème de
l'émission organisée par antenne 2 dans
le cas de sa série affaires vous
concernant lundi soir à 20h30
on m'a demandé d'animer un débat et
participeront à ce débat un membre du
gouvernement jean le garrec chargé des
nationalisations un leader syndical
henri krasucki de la cgt un patron d'une
entreprise nationale is able du secteur
industriel ambroise roux de la cge un
patron d'une banque nationale is able le
ccf jean maxime lévêque un représentant
des actionnaires rené monory ancien
ministre et un entrepreneur qui suit ces
affaires-là parce que ça le concerne
comme vous et moi
yvon gattaz rendez vous lundi soir sur
antenne 2 à 20h30 un tout autre sujet
maintenant
l'asthme et l'eczéma et le rhume des
foins des millions de français en sont
atteints chaque année non seulement ces
allergies font souffrir mais elle coûte
aussi très cher aux états unis on a
évalué à un milliard de nos francs le
coût de ces allergies
heureusement cela n'est pas inéluctable
car les médecins s'implique de plus en
plus à prévenir ces allergies c'était
d'ailleurs le thème d'un congrès
européen qui vient de se tenir à
clermont ferrand
martine allard et newell de son côté est
allé à montpellier pour voir comment se
fait cette prévention
voici l'exemple d'une femme à qui l'on
fait en ce moment un contrôle
respiratoire
vous êtes allergique depuis longtemps
oui depuis mon adolescence à quoi celle
rjccq aux poils de chat aux graminées et
tous les printemps j'ai des gros
problèmes parce que je pleure j'ai des
moments importants projets menés qui
coule j'ai les oreilles king rat du fond
de la gorge aussi qui me gratte c'est
très très dans le cas tant il y à
d'autres personnes dans votre famille
qui ont les mêmes problèmes voyez dans
ma famille à ma soeur qui non seulement
été logique non plus et asthmatique le
nous venons marais qui aussi êtes
allergiques et asthmatiques et mon fils
qui a présenté de nombreuses boutiques
otites et anti alors vous attendez un
autre enfant et cette fois si vous
prenez le problème avant la naissance
oui avant la naissance de son enfant il
faut que la femme soit prévenu que cela
risque d'avoir de l'allergie fait qui va
lui permettre de s'en occuper en bois
sans aucun traumatisme de mettre à
lèvres certain nombre de mesures et
qu'elles alors tout d'abord avant la
naissance éviter pour cette femme de
prendre des médicaments de fumée d'avoir
une vie trop agitée et s'est
immédiatement après la naissance se pose
pour les majeurs celui de l'allaitement
il faut essayer autant que possible que
cette femme nourrit c'est le même son
enfant allaite son enfant que c'est le
meilleur moyen de prévenir les allergies
en évitant le lait de vache qui est
facilement énergisante est alors quand
elle arrivait
avec son enfant la maison elle un
certain nombre de consignes a response
alors il ya 100 ans de consigner une
tonne à l'alimentation il faudra
retarder autant que possible la
variation de l'alimentation c'est à dire
la production d'une boisson des oeufs
des aliments qui peuvent contenir des
protéines allergisantes
et puis aussi le cadre de vie de cet
enfant particulier sa chambre à coucher
fait quelque chose de très important
nous avons essayé de qui n'ait pas de
contacts avec des chiens avec des chats
pas de contacts avec des chevaux de
notre côté nous avons essayé de
supprimer tout ce qui y est poussière
dans la maison en particulier passer
l'aspirateur tous les matins sur la
literie énormément aérer les pièces
nous avons supprimé aussi tous les
jouets des peluches ceci nous l'avons
fait aussi pour notre second fils qui a
actuellement quatre ans mais pour lui
nous l'avons fait dès la naissance
philippe à 4 ans et pour le moment n'a
pas d'allergie d'human une vie normale
oui qu'est ce que tu fais par exemple
qui sport beaucoup comme genre de sport
puisque et guy ce qu'est un univers de
natation nique et ça prend un jour
tennis le femina this as tu et à toi et
beaucoup de haine à l'école les ennemis
des allergiques sont partout qu'il
s'agisse de miniscules acariens ou de
pollen végétaux volant dans l'air avec
la poussière de maison
c'est pourquoi de simples changements
d'habitudes domestique parviennent
souvent pas toujours à éviter ces
allergies invalidante et ses séries de
tests et d'exploration réguliers qui
sans être douloureux peuvent tout de
même bien compliqué la vie d'un jeune
enfant
pas de fleurs pas d'animaux dans une
maison propre et sèche
cela vaut mieux que toutes les
médicalisation c'est en tout cas l'avis
de jean françois
le sport maintenant avec d'abord un
résultat de tennis thierry tulasne a
battu pascal porte en deux sets en
demi-finale du tournoi de bordeaux qui
compte pour le grand prix tulasne s'est
ainsi qualifié pour la finale où il
rencontrera l'équatorien gomez
automobile demain ce sera l'avant
dernière étape du championnat du monde
des conducteurs de formule 1 le grand
prix du canada a lieu près de montréal
et le titre va se disputer entre carlos
trautmann l'argentin et le brésilien
nelson piquet ce sont eux qui ont
réalisé les meilleurs temps aux effets
et ce sont eux aussi qui sont en tête du
championnat pour l'instant
pour une fois les renault turbo n'ont
pas brillé lors de la première séance
d'essai mathématiquement alain prost
garder une chance d'être champion du
monde mais il faudrait que fillette et
rotman et de sérieux ennuis la renault
turbo s de prost s'est réveillé un peu
tard dans la saison pour reconquérir le
titre france a tout de même réalisé une
belle performance puisqu'il a gagné
trois grands prix et c'est pourquoi il a
dit henri bodiguel il n'était pas déçu
non pas du tout pas du tout parce que
j'ai remporté trois victoires cette
année à ce jour et j'espère bien
peut-être remporter une autre on sait
pas mais je serai pas déçu toute façon
même si je ne remporte pas d'autres la
fin d'ici la fin de saison et si je ne
suis pas champion du monde
parce que pour moi c'était une saison
quand même très satisfaisant parce que
justement j'ai gagné mon premier grand
prix cette année avec renault et que je
pense que je suis ne pourrait pas être
déçu de la fin de ce championnat qui
s'annonce quand même très intéressante
et je n'ai pas encore dit mon dernier
mot pour son péno vous avez failli on
dit l'objet de nombreux contacts de la
part des currys différentes et ce qu'on
peut savoir mais quelle lesquelles la
plupart des meilleures écuries
anglaise et et 20 de français comment
réagissez vous à l'annoncé de la
retraite d'alan jones comment comprenez
vous son attitude premier sentiment que
j'ai direct je me dis à moi même c'est
dommage parce que j'aimais bien par
exemple cette année me bagarrer avec lui
malgré toutes les critiques qu'on a pu
lui
lui faire et le caractère certainement
qu'il a son caractère un petit peu
spécial qui l'a surtout vis-à-vis de la
presse et même d'autres pilotes et
mal de touches pense que c'est une
décision que je comprends très bien
parce que quand on a été champion du
monde certainement pour te faire un
petit peu de sa motivation et de plus
avec les contraintes incessantes de là
des contraintes nerveuse et c'est que
l'on a de plus en plus je pense que je
comprends un petit peu sa décision
d'arrêter
il doit peut-être un avoir un petit peu
marre de la formule 1 je les comprends
tout à fait parce que s'il n'a plus
envie de faire ce métier tu crois qu'il
faut arrêter seront fixés donc demain à
montréal pour le grand prix du canada le
tiercé maintenant il se courra à
longchamp demain et pierrette brès on le
sait dans huit jours ce sera le prix de
l'arc de triomphe mais pour
l'allongement toujours mais pour
l'instant demain donc c'est l'omnium wii
est la veille du prix de l'arc de
triomphe il y aura d'ailleurs un
quartier exceptionnelle il faut le
signaler tout de même leurs prévisions
pour le lendemain de celle omnium
l'omnium c'est un gros handicap le
handicap classique par excellence
d'ailleurs il offre 150 mille francs de
prix aux gagnants
alors certains chevaux vie cette épreuve
depuis très longtemps bien sûr c'est ce
qui explique d'ailleurs le nombre élevé
de partant malgré le forfait du numéro
13 tobiano je vous signale que tobiano
ne peut pas courir le tiercé de main
parce qu'il s'est fait très mal à
l'épaule il a du mal à marcher alors 19
chevaux seulement prendront part à cette
épreuve demain il s'agit d'un lot de
qualité il semble que cette fois ci ce
sont les chevaux du haut du tableau qui
possède les meilleures chances c'est à
dire il faudrait prendre l'échelle des
poids à partir de 54 kg je pense pour
trouver le gagnant car cette fois ci les
poids légers c'est à dire les outsiders
auront une tâche difficile aux courses
de ses 2400 mètres qu'ils devront
parcourir
kenza a déjà gagné à longchamp et sur
cette même distance
demain ces champs sont encore possibles
vous êtes l'entraîneur en forme dans le
terreau sexuellement vous venez d'en
gagner un avec kenza que la tâche sera
aussi facile
écoutez ça a l'air très compliqué c'est
une course que beaucoup d'entraîneurs
envie j'ai mon choix l'a couru sept ou
huit fois cette année
il est toujours dans les quatre premiers
j'espère que ça va se prolonger tard
cheval difficile à monter ou plutôt
facile
c'est un cheval avec lequel il faut
venir au dernier moment parce que il a
tendance à s'arrêter un petit peu c'est
embêtant pour un cheval de course et
c'est à lui que de se débrouiller avec
j'ai regardé des performances de chailly
il est souvent à l'arrivée ce cheval
mais pas à longchamp est ce que pour
longchamp ça pourra réussir que ça
changera ce sera pour lui parce qu'ils
aiment terrain et puis 2 d'autre part
ont la bêtise de poids il avait 57 kg
quand il finit 4e la longue il faut que
l'autre était en condition oui mais
c'est un handicap
moi je crois les les charges et inquiète
au plus haut si on intègre et ça je
crois d'un bon chance locaux rue des
dernières phrases
pourquoi une dernière fois parce que
dans la cave des charges elles veulent
partir en amérique je vous propose est
la suivante tous types
malgré son poids élevé 58 kilos et demi
risque de créer la surprise dans cette
épreuve
chahir que nous venons de voir si sa
dernière course en france il tord il
tentera donc de se retirer en beauté
hartwood est bien connu dans les gros
handicaps comme celui ci on peut encore
lui faire confiance piazza est un cheval
difficile espérons qu'il sera dans un
bon jour de matt white old bridge peu
avec le terrain souple se distinguer et
puis ensuite batman cole et archives
valseront les outsiders alors notez bien
leur numéro 1 sec de 9,4
11 14 et 19 merci pire est le théâtre
maintenant avec pour la rentrée la
création à paris de bent de martin
sherman au théâtre de park bench c'est
une pièce dont on va beaucoup parler
d'abord elle aborde un sujet très
difficile l'homosexualité est elle
aborde avait un très grand réalisme
ensuite elle replace le problème dans un
contexte historique peu connu la
déportation puis l'extermination des
homosexuels à partir de 34 dans
l'allemagne nazie
c'est en effet un sujet peu connu
d'ailleurs le premier témoignage sur ces
déportations n'a été publié que l'année
dernière en france dans la pièce qui
s'appelle je vous le rappelle bent les
deux principaux rôles sont tenus par
jean pierre sentiers et bruno cremer le
reportage de france roche je te défendre
m'aider
ce camp est une scène de théâtre bruno
kramer qui a perdu 15 kilos pour jouer
bent est avec jean-pierre sentier un
déporté homosexuel triangle rose son
troupeau
je comprends c'est pas du tout une
attitude politique pour défendre une
cause ou ce succès la pierre que je
trouve que la pièce est historiquement
très importante parce que tout de même
elle révèle fait qu'ils étaient très a
connu d'ailleurs par mois le premier le
fait de la persécution des homosexuels
aux 34 ce que très peu de gens
connaissent elles n'auraient pas imaginé
guy hocquenghem historiens de
l'homosexualité explique les raisons de
cette occultation
hormis les 258 personnes qui est
téléporté en tant qu'homosexuel dans les
camps il y en a très peu
trois ou quatre peut-être qu'ils ont
parlé par la suite tellement la route
était forte et tellement l'impression
qu'ils avaient qu'ils allaient souffrir
une fois de plus s'il racontait ce qui
leur était arrivé qu'ils allaient
souffrir une fois de plus en tant
qu'homosexuel tellement c'est un patient
était forte je veux dire par exemple que
pour les allemands jusqu'en 64 il y
avait une loi en allemagne qui
interdisait l'homosexualité entre
adultes consentants
par conséquent quelqu'un qui avait passé
dans les camps comme par exemple
hilfiger qui a écrit un livre qui vient
d'être publié quelqu'un qui avait passé
dans les camps tank triangles roses et
qui seraient manifestés avant 64 en
allemagne pour réclamer une hausse à ce
que le droit élémentaire à des
réparations en fête aurait été à nouveau
condamné
ça traite de l'autolog tolère aussi la
tolérance kilkis cliquet qui règne même
dans les pays libres c'est le dernier
refuge qu'il trouve et où ils sont
intouchables
je crois que c'est très important dans
la pièce c'est un peu le sommet de la
pièce c'est la dernière résistance
l'amour c'est le
c'est la seule chose qu'on ne peut pas
détruire chez vous et c'est là qu'ils se
rencontrent et qu'ils se subliment ici
vous a vu son étoile
je suis juif ou pas juif est [ __ ]
je ne voulais pas vous voulez pas quoi
écrit en bleu rose n'en voulait pas tu
m'as dit que c'était vers les régions
dit alors alors j'ai fait un arrangement
un arrangement
oui je fais ça b avec la gestapo est
vraiment une merde
la météo c'est un véritable week-ends
d'hiver que nous connaissons les pluies
violentes et les vents très forts ont
provoqué des dégâts dans l'ensemble du
pays mais particulièrement en bretagne
sur la côte d'azur puis enfin dans
l'isère tout à l'heure quatre personnes
ont été tuées et trois autres blessées
dans l'effondrement d'une maison avant
de voir les prévisions de laurent
boussier voici les images que nous avons
reçus de ce très mauvais temps sur
l'arrière-pays niçois et vents forts ont
causé de nombreux incidents dans les
alpes-maritimes et surtout dans
l'arrière-pays niçois à
saint-laurent-du-var les 180 habitants
ont dû être évacués à la suite de la
rupture d'une digue et deux villages
colomars et sainte blaise ont été isolés
ce matin à la suite d'éboulements et
d'inondations qui ont coupé les routes y
conduisant
demain et bien il fera un peu plus frais
avec encore des averses mais aussi du
soleil
bref un temps de saison il faut pas
oublier que nous sommes en automne et
que inexorablement allons vers l'hiver
mais heureusement nous ne sommes pas là
alors regardons les températures qui ont
été relevés à 14h par la météo nationale
des températures qui étaient en baisse
il ne faisait en effet que 12 degrés à
brest et à limoges le temps pour donner
bien la perturbation qui a affecté
aujourd'hui la majeure partie du pays se
décale progressivement vers l'est et
elle recouvrira le jura les vosges les
alpes est un petit peu la corse y
donnant un temps très couvert avec
encore des pluies et surtout des orages
qui pourront être localement très
violents un peu comme aujourd'hui sur
tout le reste du pays sera un peu plus
le temps sera un peu plus variable avec
encore du avec du soleil mais encore des
averses qui pourront être assez fort et
surtout un vent d'ouest de nord-ouest
qui sera lui très fort les températures
pour demain et bien elles sont en baisse
surtout le matin en moyenne de deux à
trois et même quatre degrés et enfin
pendant que vous regardez notre agenda
un mot du temps pour lundi le temps
frais va se généraliser
mais surtout on risque de voir quelques
chutes de neige sur le versant nord des
massifs montagneux mais seulement au
dessus de 1800 mètres merci laurent et
puis pendant ce week-end qui sent
nettement l'hiver on va aussi passer à
l'heure du même nom c'est en effet la
nuit prochaine que l'on change d'horaire
pratiquement cela veut dire que la nuit
sera plus longue d'une heure
oui
voilà c'est dit fin de cette édition du
journal merci il est resté avec nous le
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité ce
sera la dernière édition en fin de
programme présenté par monique karr a
passé une excellente soirée